c'est un signal d'alarme :
vous pourriez ne pas avoir d'avenir dans cette industrie.
Deux : les changements de carrière sont instinctifs.
Si vous ne dormez pas
et passez la nuit à fixer le plafond en pensant :
« Je ne peux pas vivre ma vie si je n'essaye pas de changer
ou si je n'approfondis pas cela »,
suivez votre instinct.
Il pourrait être temps de changer de carrière.
A l'inverse, ne partez pas du fait d'une douleur à court terme.
Si vous n'aimez pas votre patron
ou que les gens du bureau vous irritent,
ce n'est pas une bonne raison de changer de carrière,
car quand vous changez de carrière,
vous devez généralement démarrer en bas
et vous ressentirez de la douleur à court terme,
que ce soit via un manque de salaire ou de titre.
La douleur au travail est inévitable.
Vous êtes convaincu qu'il est temps de changer de carrière.
Il y a trois choses à faire immédiatement.
Un : réseautez, réseautez, réseautez.
Personne n'a jamais bâti de carrière sans un bon mentor
ou un bon réseau de soutien.
Réseauter, c'est obtenir tous les bons conseils
que vous pouvez obtenir.
La technologie a rendu cela simple de contacter des gens :
« Bonjour, je songe à un changement de carrière.
Auriez-vous cinq minutes pour discuter ? »
Cette passion, cette soif et cette capacité à être une éponge
attire des mentors formidables
et les gens prêts à donner de leur temps
pour vous donner des conseils.
Allez faire de nouvelles rencontres.
La seconde chose à faire immédiatement,
c'est de consolider vos finances.
En changeant de carrière,
vous débuterez soit avec un titre inférieur,
un salaire inférieur ou pas de salaire,
en particulier si vous lancez votre entreprise.
Vous assurer que vos finances sont en ordre
pour rendre la transition moins douloureuse
est très, très important.
Personnellement, quand je suis passé d'avocat
à créateur de jeux vidéo,
je voulais avoir au moins six à 12 mois d'économies à la banque.
Six à 12 mois n'est peut-être pas le bon nombre pour vous,
mais soyez honnête envers vous-même quant à ce chiffre.
Trois : si vous n'êtes pas prêt à sauter le pas à ce moment précis,
ayez une activité secondaire.
Cette activité peut être du bénévolat avec une organisation
qui est dans votre future industrie
ou lancer votre entreprise à temps partiel les week-ends.
C'est une façon d'y goûter pour voir si vous aimez vraiment cela.
Vous êtes prêt à sauter le pas
ou vous l'avez déjà fait.
Voici trois choses auxquelles vous devriez penser maintenant.
Un : ne coupez pas, je répète : ne coupez pas les ponts.
Vous avez préparé cela des années durant,
pourquoi se précipiter ?
Le monde est si petit,
surtout avec toutes ces plateformes en ligne,
que, croyez-moi, vous reverrez ces gens
et probablement au moment le moins opportun.
Deux : faites l'inventaire de ce que vous avez appris
durant vos précédentes carrières.
Nombre de ces choses s'appliquent probablement
à vos nouveaux emploi et carrière,
que ce soit interagir avec les gens, jouer en équipe
ou vous confronter aux abrutis et connards.
Toutes ces choses sont universellement applicables.
Vous trouverez des abrutis dans toutes les industries,
personne n'est immunisé, tout le monde doit le gérer
et vous savez probablement déjà le faire.
Pour finir, en débutant votre nouvel emploi, vous serez nerveux.
Ne vous inquiétez pas, respirez profondément
car voici ce que je veux vous dire :
vous êtes dans une nouvelle équipe
et tout le monde espère que vous réussirez
car votre réussite est leur réussite.
Bienvenue dans votre nouvelle carrière.